I'm watching this thing I feel like
these these two episodes really honed in
more than any other episodes on the fuel
for Michael Jordan's machine yeah oh
yeah and he feeds on grudges yes that is
his fuel that he is a vampire for
grudges those are that's the blood that
he sucks yeah and he creates these
grudges yeah right and one I guess my
first question is what does the grudge
do it gives him an extra edge and I
think he orders the it's [ __ ] you
everybody plays a little bit it's the
same reason NFL teams probably clarify
the question a grudge doesn't make you
shoot better a grudge doesn't make you
jump higher a grudge doesn't make you
run faster to focus more okay now so
that's what I'm trying to say what is
the grudge enabling him to do
there is a compares a weird competitive
thing every sports team what do they say
nobody believed in us you hey you're
giving them bulletin board material when
you guarantee a win against the other
team ever
competitors always need that thing to
make them lock in which is oh you don't
think I'm the oh you think I can't do
this right [ __ ] you Jordan is oh you
think you could just [ __ ] you we're
gonna play the finals you're gonna walk
by me even though we went to the same
college and you're not gonna acknowledge
I exist [ __ ] you right oh you're gonna
put your arm around me and tell me nice
game after you have 36 [ __ ] you it just
helps you lock in and elevate your focus
and intensity and everything and then
the game does you do perform better
usually right like that yeah I think a
grudge is like a lion trying to eat you
like a grudge is like a rock that falls
on you out in the woods like you like if
you're getting chased by line you'll tap
into a speed that you didn't know you
had like you'll push your bones and like
your ligaments to like tearing to get
away right you've seen the stories were
like the cars on the kid and the moms
able to lift the car up yeah and in the
process she like tears all the muscles
in her body yeah like it taps into a
part of your brain where you're like I
just have to do this at all cost and
nothing else matters even if it means
sacrificing my body like you can only
cognitively put your brain in to output
it like 80 percent right and then it's
only when
and you're faced with like no other
option and you escape that you're gonna
tap into the 95 96 percentile I think
right so the the interesting question is
is like why does that allow him to tap
into it like I understand if a lions
chasing me how much more focused I'll be
I'll understand if like a rock falls me
in the forest how much more focus of it
I don't understand how a coach just
walking out out of dinner it elicits the
same physical reaction or mental
reaction something about disrespect that
for him is big like if he feels a
disrespected yeah that's he's ready yeah
just make me feel disrespected a
non-locking I think you feel like you
have a I think that the intensity thing
for Jordan right is his competitive
advantage obviously as he's the best to
ever play I think this shows it that
he's the best ever play right and not
only see the best ever play he has
something that can get him to that level
at his disposal LeBron doesn't LeBron
does not have the ability to go he calls
it zero dark thirty or whatever the
[ __ ] that he doesn't have it he can
output as much as he is he wants you
know or like as he tries to but he can't
lock into the tenacity that Jordan has
yeah and Jordan I think his competitive
advantage outside have outside being the
most visit physically gifted player that
we've ever seen he had the ability to
tap into his top potential at any given
night with the smallest of stimulus yeah
literally somebody not shaking his hand
was enough for him to go to a hundred
percent no he invented stuff yeah
against the Bulls player just to create
a thing yeah I almost feel like it's a
for like OCD we're like you create this
enemy or like this fear that you have
yeah and then like you start doing these
behaviors to fix the thing that you
created in the first place yeah yeah
it's pretty amazing that he has that top
dog situation where it's like everybody
needs to kiss the ring yeah so yeah when
he first came on the Bulls he's like oh
who's the best player I'm going after
him now I'm top dog so everybody needs
to kiss my ring yeah I'll create these
enemies and it has like oh wait you're
not kissing the ring yeah but like I
mama make you yeah it is it created it
is interesting to see and maybe this is
all narrative and
maybe they're just cooking this into the
documentary but like nobody has ever
been afraid of pissing off LeBron oh you
gonna piss all the bran be careful
tomorrow nobody's ever been afraid of
pissing off Kobe you know Kobe's again
Kobe's gonna give you everything he has
every single night Jordan I don't know
about that with Kobe I think I begin
again I haven't watched enough Lakers
games to say but I think every time we
saw Kobe he tried his hardest I think
what he's saying is Kobe's mentality was
rip your heart out I need to hate you to
rip your heart yeah I just want to rip
your heart out but when he had like that
player that uh-oh people were saying
like oh he's the Kobe stop or some [ __ ]
like that like you'll see him turn
Patterson yeah I know you'll see him
like oh I'm I have a grudge against this
player so i'ma turn up and score [ __ ]
61 tonight sure justice yeah yeah he
definitely has it for sure he's super
competitive that's what every type
editor at that level has has it to a
level 1% Jordan's was like different
okay and I forgot what I was saying uh
needing the grudge needing disrespect
you said Kobe LeBron nobody's afraid
offense okay so nobody's favorite person
off LeBron I don't think I don't think
it really mattered with Kobe in the same
way I don't think so I think he was just
gonna give it no matter what and maybe
if the news media was saying so maybe if
it was like a public thing maybe it
inspired him a little bit more but if he
had to score 62 winning score 62 win or
if not I think he was just like I want
to get the championships I think Kobe
was chasing Mike people were afraid of
him yeah the way you you hear these
police players talk about Mike they're
like oh my god why'd you say that yeah
why'd you say it it's in the same way
when there's like a movie or some bad
guy
why'd you do that why'd you have to
think about that remember in
ghostbusters why'd you have to think
about the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man hey
hey don't say like why'd you have to
unlock the what does a movie or like a
bad guy or like looking I think is gangs
in New York bill the butcher is like
cutting up meat he's like this big knife
he's intimidating whoever the other guy
is that's Jordan after BG Armstrong hits
that game-winner starts talking [ __ ]
Jordan
next day in the locker room he's just
swinging a baseball bat with one hand a
cigar in his mouth he's just talking
this [ __ ] it's like a supervillain
stroking his [ __ ] cat or whatever
he's just talking about how he's gonna
ruin you x-men what is the the [ __ ]
that's Phoenix or something like that
she's a great Jean Grey or something
like that you know like if she loses it
she loses it Tasmanian Devil if they
lose it they lose there's examples of
super villains right you know it doesn't
even exist unlike regular humanity it
doesn't even exist as like humans in
movies but there are people that if they
go crazy or these super villains if they
go crazy they're kind of unstoppable
don't piss off hey don't piss Thanos off
why'd you have to do that blah blah blah
like an abusive dad you're like say the
thing to make dad mad yeah and then it
goes crazy right
so it's like let me just get so it's
like so that's what Jordan was and
that's how they saw him right like I've
never seen this before the trick with
Jordan was just to kind of be nice to
him and then hopefully he wouldn't tap
into his peak potential but he shells
with him yeah that's like every
girlfriend though yeah like you Stoeger
like put your productive that comes out
of them well but I mean I'm talking
about the Tasmanian Devil party I'm
saying by pissing them off nothing good
happens they can't do anything with it
like Jordan would win and spin around
and yell oh yeah it's just in the
interesting thing it's like most people
they get angry they actually get worse
right most people when they get upset
they throw the game away they can't
function so it's called hero ball you
guys heard his term hero ball I'm gonna
try to do it myself you know Brett Favre
are you saying that he he's lost it he's
lost a step okay now he's just throwing
interceptions and the [ __ ] playoffs
right and with Jordan the opposite thing
happened usually when people tap into
that aggression and that anger bad
things happened because Jordan was the
hero I think I think not only was he the
hero I think that he was so good that's
what I mean we've never seen somebody on
this level of greatness I think he was
so far superior I would say a minimum
two
percent better than anybody else quiet
any given was even close at the time I
don't know I don't know I mean you can't
even put Reggie Miller in the same
ballpark you know I think I love Reggie
Miller
I want anybody 5% not even close it's 20
25 percent and you know what it is this
is what it is when he taps into it it's
Jordan playing against his little
brother not his actual relationship it's
anyone playing against their younger
sibling that's what he that's how far
above everybody he was in the league
when he was able to tap into what he
wanted
he was playing against a younger sibling
and that's pretty amazing at any point
in time going our i'ma drop 60 a night
i'ma drop 36 and a half cuz that
[ __ ] to score 37 on me in a full
game no we the idea we compare it like
no disrespect to Cole people when you
think about the stats they said Jordan
averaged 40 points a game for an entire
playoff series seven times not [ __ ]
crazy that is in a league that wasn't
that high scoring and didn't like you
were allowed to hit everybody on the
perimeter like crazy numbers this guy
would put up he was he could play hero
ball effectively
[Applause]